nouvelle fonctionnalité qui vient
d'arriver sur WhatsApp vous pouvez
désormais modifier vos messages
d'ailleurs c'est bizarre que cette
fonctionnalité n'existait pas avant vous
pouvez venir les modifier pendant
uniquement 15 minutes 15 minutes et pas
une de plus et par exemple vous avez
plus une faute de frappe dans un message
si vous n'avez pas envoyé le bon emoji à
la bonne personne par exemple et bien
vous pouvez venir le modifier très
facilement je vous montre comment ça se
passe vous tapez un petit message par
exemple ceci est un message que je veux
modifier et vous mettez à côté un petit
emoji tennis pour éviter la confusion
vous l'envoyez et ensuite vous dites
mince je voulais pas envoyer les emoji
tennis vous laissez appuyer votre doigt
dessus et vous avez l'icône modifié qui
apparaît et là vous me supprimez ça et
vous mettez des petits cœurs et c'est
parti ce message a été modifié pour tous
les membres de cette discussion sur la
dernière version de WhatsApp et si par
exemple je viens modifier une discussion
qui n'a rien à voir vous voyez je laisse
mon doigt appuyer dessus et là modifier
n'apparaît pas c'est donc une
fonctionnalité tout bête mais qui va en
aider plus dense je trouve ça cool
d'ailleurs dites-moi vous ce que vous en
pensez dans les commentaires